as a Patriots fan I'm [ __ ] sitting  there listening to people defending  Sammy Sosa Mark McGuire and Barry Bonds  going everybody cheats you know the  numbers of the numbers  they count I hate that trying to say  that they count  I hate that it doesn't count those as a  white guy now I mean how much of a  [ __ ] have a steam  you want some juice into bleaching Sammy  Sosa looks like you were the perm yeah  um out of all the [ __ ] that I've  seen people do cork bats and all of this  type of [ __ ] the number one [ __ ]  thing dude is if you're on performance  enhancing drugs  performance enhancing drugs it that  that's it's it's [ __ ] steroids you  feel like it's the first game of the  year  the whole year  you're coming up there feeling like a  [ __ ] like you're on one of those  Marvel guys